hey grammarians i want to talk about
prepositions but before i do i'm going
to draw you a little hamster
is it a hamster is it a tiny bear who
knows
we're just going to call it a hamster
little
little rodent type creature
now i'm going to use this critter to
establish what prepositions are and what
they do
because in addition to there being a
hamster there's also going to be this uh
this box
so what prepositions do is they
establish relationships between stuff in
place and time so it can show it can
show us
where things are
when things are
and how things are
let me let me demonstrate so okay so
using just this hamster and this box
we can move this box around
and talk about how the hamster relates
to the box right so right now
the box is under the hamster let's write
that down
right the box is under the hamster that
word under is a preposition because it's
establishing this relationship of where
it's connecting the box to the hamster
the box is under
the hamster
but if i move it up like so now we can
say the box
is over the hamster
but let's get rid of the box
and let's imagine that our hamster
is having a midlife crisis
and our hamster decides it's going to go
out and it's going to splurge on a
fabulous new hat
it's an enormous top hat
a little band in the center
just a big old silly abe lincoln style
stove pipe top hat
now another use for prepositions is we
can talk about
when things are in relation to each
other so i could say
before
the hamster got the hat
and
after
the hamster got the hat
right and these words after and before
express relationships in time
but another interesting thing that
prepositions can do is they can also
help express how something is or how
it's what it's for what its use is you
know so we could say um
that
you know this hat is for parties
or is for wearing at parties
oh and at also is a preposition
this hat is for wearing at parties so
this is
the the how
and this part is the where
so what's the purpose of the hat well we
established that with the word for the
hat is for wearing and where is it
supposed to be worn at parties that's
the where we can also use a word like of
to express
um
the the how relationship um
and that's that's just sort of to say
what belongs to whom so we could say you
know that is the hat of the hamster
that
is
the hat
of
the hamster so that's what prepositions
are in the most basic sense they can
help you figure out what the
relationship is between two things in
time and space
you know or or how one thing relates to
another
so you can figure out when where and how
using
prepositions you can learn anything
david out